amazon is acquiring mgm the studio
behind james bond and rocky for 8.45
billion dollars this is a business
insider story
they said on wednesday that it would buy
hollywood giant mgm hollywood giant mgm
for 4.48.45 amazon acquisition mgm
studio could mean a big expansion of
amazon's prime
streaming inventory to include mgm's big
name movies and tv shows these include
the james bond rocky creed
pink panther franchise that's big for
adam i know you're a pink panther guy
legally blonde a star is born uh it's
tv shows include handmaid's tale fargo
shark tank real housewives the real
finance value behind this deal
is the treasure trove of ip in the deep
catalog that we plan to re
imagine and develop together with mgm's
talented team mike hopkins senior vice
president of prime video
and amazon studios set in a press
release the sale of amazon is a stunning
the sale to amazon is a stunning finale
for a studio
brand that a decade ago was deeply in
debt mgm sold to sony and a group of
investors including private equity firm
providence equity for three billion
dollars plus 1.9 billion dollars in debt
back in 2004 not bad for mgm
but also a big play for amazon so what's
amazon doing with this
are they planning on competing and going
directly with netflix is this a disney
thing what are they doing what do they
want to do that's exactly what they want
to do is it a takeover is it competing
well don't forget amazon if you kai go
to this website real quick
r-e-l-e-n-t-e-s-s-com
relentless.com
my favorite part of that is that you
didn't think kai knew how to spell
relentlessness he is
struggling where does that lead you to
amazon.com i'll said it before and i
said it again
relentless.com will take your ass right
to amazon.com they have no
intention of stopping there's another
story on here that they're basically
competing with cvs and walgreens because
they're opening up pharmacies yeah
they're coming after movies they're
coming after pharmacies they're coming
after
anchor stores in the mall they are
coming after every single thing
out there jeff bezos just bought a what
a 500 million dollar
yacht like the the money is
non-stop relentless so now let's talk
about this mgm play are they going to
try to compete with netflix
you betcha are they going to try to
compete with disney plus you betcha also
in the news you got warner media and
discovery and the hbo thing
so in my mind all these big
um massive
companies are just the rich are getting
richer the bigger getting bigger and the
the people that have power getting more
powerful last thing here with
amazon going hollywood don't forget what
happened during the pandemic shutdown
all the movie theaters got closed right
every single one of them
but basically it solidified that these
streaming services can just go direct to
market
and roll out movies amazon saw that and
said bingo let's just get in that
on that play and that's exactly what
they're doing they i agree they were
they were competing with netflix anyway
already they were they were already
ahead of hbo max they were already ahead
of disney now this takes them to another
level don't forget they they have
streaming rights to the nfl
they have streaming rights to major
league baseball they're doing something
which i think is brilliant with those
streaming rights they're going to have
multiple different um options for
watching the games they're going to have
an all-female-only crew they're going to
have a
a young crew an old cruiser you're going
to be able to choose the people that you
that are commentating the game that
you're watching you're gonna have
multiple different options they're gonna
have the director's
view where you can see everything at
once so i mean they're really innovative
and if you want to learn more about
amazon and jeff bezos you can check out
a show called before they were
billionaires on this channel uh called
uh you know valuetainment
a very very handsome man in an
ill-fitting suit did a great five-minute
uh
segment on it you should check it out
but um
the bigger question is what's it going
to take for us to break up amazon
like you said they're gobbling up
everything well if if your daughter
decides to
if your daughter decides to do a
lemonade stand out front jeff bezos
might put an offer on it
so i mean at what point do we need to
look
uh at this the way teddy roosevelt look
at looked at the the robber barons the
way that
you know the the tech giants have
completely cornered our society the way
that carnegie and rockefeller did at the
turn of the last century
and say all right this is this is
restricting the marketplace these guys
are too big
too powerful you know one of the stories
we didn't talk about last time that we
had on here kai
was the apple story in fortnite we may
have talked about it
we talked about okay so apple and
fortnite so fortnite's argument is the
fact that how many
what percentage of app sales are right
now being done on the ios what's the
percentage kai
in the 80s the number is astronomical
okay
go look up a a you know percentage of
app
sales ios droid see what control apple
has right
so apple's saying hey fortnight you can
be on you're off because you found a
creative way to not pay the 30
right that's the whole challenge between
apple and fortnite what's the number i'm
actually curious that
the app store monopoly i want to know
how much ios
controls android is going to go go down
a little bit go no the other way the
other way the other way
yeah you okay you were like literally
right there
go slightly down oh now we got the box
slightly go down right there a little
more a little more right there okay
androids are around 110 million or 20 24
something
so 65 percent i'm trying to find out
what's the difference 71
of total app revenue 2020 ios generator
47.6
google play made 31.9 okay so it's
relatively close ios is 111 billion
dollars
so 65 percent okay 65
is apple what's monopoly is it monopoly
54
isn't there 70 okay so 65
is apple right okay so check with a
monopoly is the percentage
yeah so so you you look at companies
like this you look at what apple's doing
you look at what amazon's doing
you look at how you're saying how soon
you break them apart right you you get
them to
break up 75 at this point of the game
who okay it's 75
at this point of the game even 65
percent
how the hell do you compete with that
yeah how does a smaller company come up
and compete with that you got 65
and they get to tell you no they get to
say no you can't do this so now
and amazon can say no to you as a
customer because they have aws the best
hosting service
amazon can say we're not going to sell
your book amazon can announce
the level of control and influence with
someone like this is the one part where
bernie sanders
makes an argument with some of these
bigger companies and breaking up these
big money
it's it's it's it's one too many it's
one too many so who's next round
you put your career on the line i was
there for it you put your career on the
line you were the
very first person you beat rogan to it
you were the very first person to have
alex jones on when he was de-platformed
and you put you put your hole on 9 11.
you put your whole youtube channel up up
in the air for that one
and oh sorry i didn't want to cut you
off but you brought up the point that
i'm trying to make right now
amazon policy punishes consumers dc sue
claims so
the district of uh of columbia attorneys
are actually going after amazon for
anti-trust grounds monopolies
it illegally raises prices this is
already happening yeah and
it goes beyond that click on that story
it's one thing about price gouging it's
one thing about market control
another story we're not gonna get to
today is that um you know project
veritas and james o'keefe uh
they basically got facebook to admit
that they are stratifying posts based on
based on on political they're
aggregating posts and then they're
stratifying the their algorithm based on
political affiliation
so they're literally suppressing
viewpoints all right and
now as a private company right nobody's
going to tell you what to do with your
companies and i get that
but at some point when there's only five
companies and they collude together
you are creating an environment where
now
all your information your entire
zeitgeist
is controlled by three four people you
know and again that's where someone like
you is so important someone that
something like valuetainment is so
so so valuable to have an independent
voice to be able to question
authority to be able to speak truth to
power but then i mean dude you could
wake up like i got like
my page got demonetized i told you i i
woke up one day
i said though i posted the wrong uh the
wrong comment i
i sent the wrong video and i woke up and
they were like boop your page has been
demonetized and your reach is restricted
how many times were you worn before it
happened it's three strikes
so you were warned twice but here's the
deal i was demonetized for the truth
i didn't say anything that was untrue
and i'm i'm not saying
what you said was right or wrong but
what are you saying give you a fair
warning but but
if they give you fair warning what does
that mean if i give you i don't know
if i give you fair like if you were if
you weren't warned you're like if i give
you
if i give you fair warning and i say
adam if you keep sitting there i'm gonna
punch you adam if you keep sitting here
i'm going to punch you and then i punch
you
did you do anything to deserve getting
punched and i could be like well i gave
you a fair warning what are you supposed
to do get out the room
the only argument there can be made is
if it's in your house
if it's in your house and you tell them
leave my house leave my house
leave my house punch meaning the
argument i gotta talk to sue and uh
dennis praise the whole block i talked
to sue and dennis prager you know who
they are prager university and i talked
to them when they were suing youtube and
they were going back and forth saying
the fact that you can't do this because
it's freedom of speech
and all this a first amendment all this
other stuff they said the law the
lawyers didn't go on their side and you
know they have strong attorneys sue
herself as an attorney they said
the argument was what the u.s count you
know what u.s stands for with freedom of
speech our first amendment has nothing
to do what private companies
and public companies have to do yeah so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]